who is the United States spying on in
Europe how can abusers of international
intelligence be avoided on their arrival
to the US Congress MEP hope to see
answers to these questions the Congress
kicked off was a meeting with mike
rogers german of the permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence we're starting
to highlight some areas where we think
we can work together to to cover our
differences protect our relationship
between our EU allies in the United
States and still protect the ability to
collect information that keeps both our
allies in the United States safe how to
strike the right balance between
security and privacy for the EU the
revelations of NSA phone tapping has
cast doubt on the extent to which the
American administration is respecting
this boundary and we have consent to
about security and we made that very
clear but also there is a balance to be
struck with privacy of citizens and I
think these [ __ ] changes need to be
billed at that very important trust the
director of the NSA has dismissed
accusations of spying on the phone
records of millions of European citizens
he claims that their European partners
shared the data and wisdom European
delegation reporter have met with the
NSA director they state that even if
this information is confirmed it won't
change the underlying issue if that's in
case it has to be finished to a full
stop but it's not it does not if one is
a sinner he can i use himself than there
are also sinners the allegations remain
of mass surveillance and individual
spying allegations and it's very
important we try and get to the truth of
what is happening truth is hard to
ascertain in such intelligence agencies
well known for their opacity according
to young Philip alleged specialist in
the field of digital rights and data
protection a transatlantic agreement
must be found what we need to do is to
build up new rules on privacy protection
and uncommon standards for the control
of intelligence services so that people
get back trust and democracy and rule of
law clear rules and a legal framework
could serve to reassure European
companies at a time
when the free trade agreement is being
negotiated